all right it is time for drew's news
your daily scream into the good news
pillow oh how about we all been there
and with me at the desk is a man i could
scream all day long to is ross matthew
that's right hi everybody
well it's time for some headlines rossi
literally all right first up drew you
you know we we all know that you are an
icon whether you say no i am not yes no
who thinks they are
not my cup of tea but go on thank you
though thank you you're welcome and for
many many reasons one of them is the
terrifying way that you died in the
opening of scream right guys right
iconic
that was fun to do well we all agree
with that and so does kristen stewart
people reports kristen it recently
revealed that for scream four they asked
her to die in the first few minutes of
the film and you know what she told them
she was like no i'm not doing it i can't
do drew i can't touch that this is a
true story they wanted to sort of do an
homage to your character casey in the
new in scream for and she turned it down
because she was like no i could never do
it like drew did it
look she's hearing this for the first
time
i'm also such an uber fan of hers like i
can't even believe she knows i'm alive
and then
like i
i oh my gosh oh
yeah i mean
okay kristen stewart i could never be
bella i could never be diana
i could never be you in anything that
you ever do i am so enamored with you
and
i have been for so long i'm so i'm i'm
i'm thrilled that i have a kristen
stewart stamp of approval on anything
i've ever done in my life yes she loves
you my god i love her so much oh do you
know she also turned down the lead role
in the ross matthews story for the same
reason she's like i can't do that i
can't
i won't i won't he doesn't do well
i really do want to see that i know i'd
watch it i would um oscar funny enough
our story uh next is a casting news
story um sony is following up their mega
smash hit spider-man with a female
spider hero movie we've talked about it
on the show because our friend dakota
johnson will be none other than madame
webb but
it gets even crazier deadline reports
another incredible actress will be
joining her ladies and gentlemen sydney
sweeney will be joining her and when i
mean sydney sweeney i mean that's sydney
sweeney cover of cosmo
i mean she's hot off euphoria as she's
scene stealing and white literally lotus
yeah she's been on the show she was so
nice and so lovely
and she's having such a moment you know
that show that you love and that
character you love it's her it's her and
she's it's so great to see
an actress like come into her moment and
then get that spotlight kind of role and
also like let's face it at the box
office the way the world works now with
streaming habits economics
it's usually the marvel movies that are
making the money so to see these two
extraordinary women
in a marvel movie i'm like yes thank you
so much i'm so into this movie
[Music]